Kinto cor is a protein Rich structure
which is present around the centromere
of metaphysic
chromosome kinor regulates equal
segregation of the chromosome during
cell division so this is how a proper
and a defective segregation look like
and kinord ensures that the segregation
is proper because it attach and attracts
microtubule all the information about
the structure of Kor was obtained from
electron microscopy studies so let us
look at the kinor structure in bit more
details so there are three zones in
Kinto cor inner Kinto cor the outer
Kinto cor and the outer fibrous layer
fibrous layer is really important to
attract
microtubules and there are several
protein complexes present in the
kineticore like ndc80 complex dam1
complex watch the full video to know
more about it